وبحسب بيان لرئاسه الحكومه اللبنانيه فقد
طلب رئيس الحكومه حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه نجيب مقاطي من وزاره الخارجيه
تقديم شكوى عاجله الى مجلس الامن بشان
انفجار بيروت وقد ندد مقاطي باغتيال صالح
العاروري نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس وصف الاغتيال بانه جريمه اسرائيليه
اخرى تهدف الى ادخال لبنان في مرحله جديده
وحذر ميقاتي من لجوء المستوى السياسي
الاسرائيلي الى تصدير اخفاقاته في غزه نحو
حدود لبنان الجنوبيه وكذا مقاط تمسك لبنان
بالقرارات الدوليه لا سيما القرار
1701 قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الهيان ان اغتيال صالح العاروري
عمليه ارهابيه جبانه تثبت ان النظام
الصهيوني لم يحقق ايا من اهدافه بعد
اسابيع من جرائم الحرب في غزه ورغم الدعم
الامريكي واضاف عبد اللهيان في سلسله
منشورات على منصه اكس ان انشطه الاله
الارهابيه للنظام الصهيوني في بلدان اخرى
تشكل تهديدا حقيقيا للسلام والامن وانذار
خطيرا لامن بلدان المنطقه حسب
وصفه اعربت قوه الامم المتحده المؤقته في
لبنان اليونيفل عن قلقها اذا اي احتمال
للتصعيد قد يكون له عواقب مدمره على جانبي
الخط الازرق وناشد المتحدث باسم قوه الامم
المتحده المؤقته في لبنان تواصل جميع
الاطراف لوقف اطلاق النار وضبط النفس